news alert for all of you the resume is
some 1992 I don't think I've ever
looked at a resume in my life
the young woman came up to me and said
you made a video that changed my life
you said it was okay for me to quit if I
was in a toxic job even though I was
only in it for six months because I was
scared that if my resume had me
somewhere for six months it would look
bad and you told me it was okay and I
quit and I've been so much happier I
think a lot of people are staying in
jobs for one or two years after they
realize the job sucks or is not for them
two or three weeks in and I think the
reason they're doing that is they're
worried that it's going to look bad on
their resume and I just don't think
that's as real as people think in
today's environment every company that
gives a that you were a
stay-at-home mom and don't realize that
the skill sets that you learn of raising
children are wildly wildly relevant for
the world we live in today is a
company that you don't want hiring you
in the first place